I used to be a part of the blue bubble I
I was 100% a left leaning person who
lived in Los Angeles more and more
people are waking up the average
apolitical kind of default Lefty because
the entire cultural apparatus B
basically um replicates lefties that's
what the system creates lefties and then
you have to wake up at some point more
and more people are waking up because of
that uh this is Joe Rogan from his show
this week talking about how he has woken
up to the leftist lunacy over time this
is what we're seeing so over time you
and I who used to be on the left are now
like where's the left where are you guys
you guys are so far away I can't even
see you you're out of your mind you're
you're get you're chopping off and and
giving little kids hormone blockers you
have no idea what the long-term
consequences are you're ignoring the
health risks you won't even talk about
the health risks you you use things like
gender AFF confirming care what are you
saying what are you saying when you're
talking about children why are you just
accepting this cuz it's it's a noble
thing to blurt out so everybody goes
you're on the right team that's what it
is it's not like oh my God what are we
doing to kids it's not like oh my God
what are we doing to San Francisco it's
not like oh my God why are we letting
these violent criminals out of jail it's
oh my God why are we defunding the
police what are you doing yeah you can't
say any of those things you say any of
those things you're announcing Austin
people are great people they're really
nice they're nice they're not heads
they're not Hollywood people they're not
lost in this fake world of leftist
ideology that everybody's trapped in
they're just people they're just regular
people man and those people exist
outside of these these blue bubbles
where everyone's gone insane well I used
to be a part of the blue bubble I I was
100% a left-leaning person who lived in
Los Angeles I was 100% I never voted
Republican my whole life I was very left
leaning especially with like any social
issues when it comes to financial things
I'm a little bit more conservative but
at the end of the day way more left than
I am right but California went nuts man
it's gone like full communist it's out
of its mind and their approach to law
enforcement is so insane it's so insane
the no cash bail the letting people out
for committing violent crimes the not
stopping people for steal up to whatever
money it is is what is it $900 now I
think they raised it I think they made
it a little higher San Francisco is
non-existent San Francisco most of San
Francisco is emptied out of like big
chain stores and big department stores I
I would even do stand up there anymore
it's crazy they ruined it they ruined
the city I mean you can bring it back
the structure is still there but You'
have to have some hardcore Rudy Giuliani
type mother come in there and knock
heads wow and nobody wants that nobody
wants that they're peace love and
granola and wear a mask I'm in
the middle now I'm in the middle I'm in
the middle I never I never thought I
would ever say that never never it only
happened this last year right exactly I
just went I can't do it
anymore you know I mean people that you
thought were aligned with you are like
now now like mad at you about they're in
a cult they're in a cult it's it's got
all I
mean Mark andrees who's a brilliant
venture capitalist guy explained it to
me in in in very clear terms like what
the definition of a cult is how you can
get excommunicated how you get shamed
for having different opinions the group
think the whole he's like it's a cult
and he's right he's 100% right yeah yeah
it's just hard to say because then
people in the cult will attack you but
they're not attacking you for a
reasonable it's not logical like the way
they're attacking you they're attacking
like someone attacks religious beliefs
yeah and some of these religious beliefs
that it get it gets into these weird
gray areas like like trans people in
women's bathrooms like says who says who
how do you know that's a real trans
person how do you not know that's a
creep that don't wants to pull his dick
out in front of kids cuz those are real
yeah and if all you that guy was a
convicted uh sex offender yeah yeah and
he was doing that look those guys are
real it doesn't mean trans people aren't
real also but those guys are real and to
even say that those guys are real you
get excommunicated you get treated like
you're a Nazi why I left the left by Joe
Rogan um okay you get the point you get
the point who is closer to reality is it
Joe Rogan right there talking about the
lunacy of gender quote affirming care
and talking about the craziness of
letting all the criminals out on the
street of Cali or is it the guy we
started the show with who was Pro
chopping genitals off kids John Stewart
and who was running cover for the
governor of California Gavin Nome who
has destroyed that state so those the
lines are being drawn right now what I
would love to see out of Joe Rogan is
finally say it man I get it you didn't
have the balls to to support Trump last
time okay fine will you do it this time
and I say that as someone that wasn't
even supporting Trump a couple weeks ago
but it is pretty damn obvious where
things are at right now so everyone is
going to have to take aide and everyone
is going to have to call balls and
Strikes honestly and well no the best
way to go about doing things would be to
call balls and Strikes honestly and and
then let the chips fall where they may I
get that not everyone will do that uh
but be brave and and fight fight fight
man because between the border between
Iran between the chopping of the kids
genitals it's an awful lot and uh
there's got to be a way out of this
thing